[Musique]
nez qui coulent éternuements répétitions
tous une légère fièvre qui ne dépasse
pas 38 degrés c'est sûr vous avez
attrapé un rhume mais de quelle manière
robert tu es beau médecin généraliste
nous en dit plus le rhume qui est
synonyme de rhinite est une inflammation
du nez que dans la majorité des cas due
à un virus c'est pas parce que une
personne prend froid reste au froid
qu'il a plus de risque d'être atteints
par ce virus quand on dit j'ai attrapé
froid ça ne veut donc pas dire grand
chose car le rhume est une maladie
virale
mais puisque ce n'est pas le froid qui
provoque le rhume pourquoi sommes nous
bien plus enrhumé l'hiver que le reste
de l'année
plusieurs raisons qui explique la
recrudescence du rhume l'hiver la
promiscuité des personnes qui se
regroupent l'hiver dans des endroits qui
sont moins chers et que ce fréquenté
l'été et d'autre part c'est un virus qui
se propage très facilement par voie
aérienne et par contact en hiver
contrairement à l'été nous vivons plus
les uns sur les autres bien au chaud et
les virus regan
la propagation du virus se fait par deux
mécanismes d'une part de manière
aérienne c'est des gens qui se mouche
qui éternue et qui projette des
gouttelettes invisible mais parfois très
loin et l'autre mécanique c'est par le
contact les mains les objets souillés
qui transmettent le virus
regardez ces images incroyables
lorsque nous éternuant nous expulsions
des millions de gouttelettes chargées de
virus alors pour éviter de contaminer
votre entourage peau c'est bien éternuer
dans votre coude à jeter vos mouchoirs
et à vous laver les mains régulièrement
vous l'avez sûrement constaté les
enfants en bas âge sont très vulnérables
face aux rhumes
ce sont les petits bébés parce que leur
système immunitaire n'est pas tout à
fait au point les anticorps qui ont été
transmis par la mère s'épuisent
rapidement et donc il faut qu'ils
recréent eux mêmes leur l'immunité et
les jeunes enfants par l'intermédiaire
surtout des écoles où ils vivent en
contact très rapproché le rhume ne nous
cloue pas au lit contrairement une
grippe par contre il nous empoisonnent
la vie en particulier notre nez
et oui quand on est enrhumé notre nez
bouché ou cool à grande eau une
sensation très inconfortable ce guide
c'est le mucus nasale nous en produisons
même quand nous ne sommes pas aux rues
mais son rôle est essentiel
explications de maurice rambert médecin
orl
il a pour but d' emilie fier le nez et
surtout il permet de capter des
poussières des virus et de les éliminer
vers le fond du nez et de la gorge la
production principale aiguë et de façon
tout à fait inconsciente on s'en
aperçoit même pas ce mucus qu'on appelle
familièrement la morve nous en aval ont
jusqu'à un litre par jour sans nous en
rendre compte et deux fois plus lorsque
nous sommes en rue mais pourquoi
bien le nez va se défendre il va se
défendre parce qu'il est agressée et
donc des glandes qui sont au niveau du
nez vont couler comme de l'eau pour
essayer d'éliminer les particules
virales
la morve a tendance à nous dégoûter
pourtant elle défend notre organisme et
vous allez découvrir qu'elle est loin
d'être aussi sale qu'on ne le pense
direction l'espace pierre gilles de
gennes à paris paul boniface médiateurs
scientifiques et des deux louis et
kourtney 9 ans va réaliser une drôle
d'expérience bonjour louis bonjour
courtney parce que vous avez déjà eu un
gros rhume qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on est malade qu'on a un gros rhume ya
un truc qui sort d'une et ça s'appelle
comment si la mort ne sait comment la
morve qui lui a dû en passer du mucus on
va fabriquer aujourd'hui le premier
ingrédient qu'il nous faut c'est
l'ingrédient qui a le plus à notre corps
l'aqua dans notre corps de l'eau on est
plein d'eau en effet l'organisme d'un
adulte est constitué de 65 % d'eau et
chez un nourrisson cette proportion
atteint les 75% donc pour fabriquer de
la morve il faut de l'eau est ensuite
est-ce que vous avez déjà goûté la mort
ça quel goût c'est un petit peu salé ont
passé en fait dans y'a du sel le
deuxième ingrédient cdu seule il ya
quelque chose dedans qui le rend gluant
collant dans notre corps ce qui fait ça
c'est des protéines qu'on appelle des
muses in
seul notre corps peut produire ces
protéines notre médiateur la remplace
donc par un ingrédient très similaires
on sait ce que c'est la gélatine
il y en a dans les bonbons exactement
notre miss teen est aussi composée de
sucre c'est ce qui donne son effet
collant à la morve les enfants ajoutent
du sirop de maïs donc du sucre on a
recréé la consistance du mucus ou de la
morgue
[Musique]
pour voir le rôle de sept morts devant
notre nez faisant un test paul prend
deux assiettes et à notre morve
artificielle sur l'une d'entre elles
puis il donne aux enfants de la poudre
de craie pour simuler des corps
étrangers vous allez on prend un petit
peu dans votre main vous allez souffler
ça sur les assiettes 1 2 3
alors qu'est ce qu'on voit
exactement
regardez sur l'assiette recouverte de
notre mucus la craie en poudre vient se
coller alors que sur l'a7 propres elle
glisse
quand on a du mucus à l'intérieur du nez
dans la gorge dans les poumons les
poussières microbes et virus qui passent
dans l'air qu'on respire il reste collée
dessus alors que s'il n'y avait pas de
mucus tout ça ça pourrait rentrer et
aller dans nos poumons ou à l'intérieur
de nous vous l'avez compris ce sens ce
mucus nous serions malades bien plus
souvent
mais quand notre n'est totalement bouché
à quoi est ce dû à un trop plein de
mucus
pour le savoir nous allons explorer
l'intérieur du nez de notre journaliste
avec un fibroscope
[Musique]
voilà donc là en rendant menée
sur la face interne du nez de louis se
trouvent les cornées ils sont recouverts
d'un tissu lit ce qu'on appelle la
muqueuse mais lorsqu'on a le nez bouché
cette muqueuse change d'aspect
lorsqu'on est très enrhumé la muqueuse
nasale va gonfler notamment au niveau
des cornets il y a effectivement du
mucus mais c'est pas de mucus qui bouge
c'est pas une accumulation de mucus qui
bouche c'est la congestion des cornets
qui va boucher n'est obligé de passer
une respiration
il n'y a donc pas de bouchon de morve
lorsque votre nez bouché alors évitez de
vous moucher car si vous forcez trop
vous risquez d'irriter encore plus les
cornées les au fait comment peut-on
soigner un rhume le rhume en soi ne se
ne se soigne pas il n'y a pas de
médicaments contre le rhume et tout doit
disparaître en une semaine dix jours la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya des moyens
pour vous rendre la vie moins pénible un
peu de de paracétamol par exemple faire
baisser la fièvre est un peu de fièvre
voir beaucoup parce que comme on a une
respiration un certain nombre du cal pas
se dessécher et puis on peut laver le
nez avec un peu de sérum physiologique
justement pour essayer de rétablir un
petit peu la fonction normale du mucus
vous savez maintenant ce qu'est vraiment
un rhume et comment notre nez lutte pour
en venir à bout alors à vos mouchoirs
mais pas trop et prenez votre mal en
patience